How does one know if their gallbladder and liver are working efficiently?
You speak much about that in the seven pages of detox, but I'm missing how to know if they are functioning well.
That popied one is obvious, the others not so much.
So how to know if your gallbladder is working? Well, there are some questions that you could ask.
I'm actually making some new videos on gallbladder function.
But questions you could ask, guard me, do how do I tolerate fatty foods? Well, yeah, no trouble to or some people might say they can just talk to somebody.
You know, the day it said, no, no, I tolerate them really well.
I said, good, you can eat fatty foods with only problems. Oh, no, I never eat fatty foods.
Why don't you eat fatty foods because they cause problems? Well, then you don't tolerate them very well.
So if you can't tolerate fatty foods that's a side of gallbladder issues, certainly there's blood tests that can show that you have gallbladder issues, meaning that if you have elevated really rumored that we know you have some blockage in the bile duct most commonly.
Functional gallbladder issues, the most, the most appropriate way to diagnose functional gallbladder issues is to get an ultrasound.
So you get an ultrasound of your gallbladder to see, you know, really how much sludge slash gallstones that you have in a gallbladder.
That would be the thing to do.
So I have gallbladder flush information on the seven, seven phases of these talks course that you could look at to and just supporting the gallbladder and all of you are supporting the gallbladder.
If you're following, if you're doing coffee and a bus and you're doing test real packs for and hot packs over your gallbladder liver area. So that's what we have all of you doing that.
So if you are doing that, you are supporting the gallbladder. How do you know if your liver is working correctly.
Well, you cannot, there isn't any test out there as far as lab to know how your liver pathways are, how efficient they're working.
When we look at your genetics, we look at, do you have any defects in the central field, people are 50 in the pod pathway and the net pathways, et cetera, et cetera.
To look, if you have defects in phase one, phase two, phase three liver pathways, but that doesn't tell us functionally how efficiently they're working.
Now we can get some clues to liver functionality by looking at a complete metabolic pathway in the AST, ALT, GGT, alcohol and phosphatase will tell us if those are elevated can tell us that there is inflammation in the liver.
The person has elevated cholesterol, it can tell us that there's some sort of inflammation in the liver for sure.
Does that tell us the efficiency of the detox pathways? There's no way to know that except other symptoms. So by a toxic person, because I, because you know, there's, there's other evidence of toxins meeting like symptoms like rashes and, you know, just feeling ill health and having to diagnose cancer.
Then we just want to support those pathways. So it's, it's, you don't even need to look at a person's genetics for their detox pathways to know that everybody needs some help with their detox pathways.
The truth is, is that you're detoxing constantly and you want to decrease the amount of toxification that's happening on a constant basis so that you are detoxing at a greater rate than your toxin.
That's not even worth that you're toxifying yourself. It's probably not a word either. So following to what increase your rate of detoxification so you do everything you can possibly within reason to help support that.
So having, you know, getting an ultrasound of your gallbladder to make sure that there's not, it's just not a lot of backup there can be helpful, especially if you're going to go there, you're have gone through chemo and you've gone through, you know, a lot of toxin, you know, issues in your, in your lifetime that could be helpful.